the next question relates to a person
that is swallowing his or her own saliva
during the fast is this a permitted
act as far as swollowing the Sala is
concerned it is a normal act it's a
natural act and today science tells us
that there are several liters of saliva
being secreted by the salivary gland
every day and it is normal it it's
natural that the saliva a human being
gulp sit down he swalls it and this
can't be avoided and Allah says in the
Quran inah bakar chapter number two
verse 185 when it tells you that you
should fast for the full month of
Ramadan and those who are on a journey
they can make up the priod later on then
it says Allah subhana wa ta'ala wants to
make it easy for you and does not want
to put you in a difficulty Allah says in
chapter number
22 verse number 78 Allah subhana wa
ta'ala does does not want to give you
hardship in your Dean in your religion
so but natural sin soling saliva is a
normal act and I know that some people
keep on frequently spitting out and I
have some of my friends who do that
thinking it's Haram to swall and they
keep on spitting and imagine if you have
to do it the full day you cannot even
offer your Salah properly because then
you offer Salah takes a few minute and
in few minutes also Salah gets gathered
so will you be concentrating on spitting
the Sal out or on Allah subhana tala if
you're reading the Quran you'll have to
keep on spitting out out side always and
I know some people always keep uh maybe
a container always spitting out not
knowing the ruling so if a person follow
the saliva normal saliva which comes in
the mou it cannot be avoided at all same
way a person when he breeds the dust
with which a person goes to a city which
is polluted and there's dust particles
and you breathe that and some of it goes
in your lungs or it goes so it's all
this is permissible because this is a
normal dat act and these do not violate
your fast at all